using the python debugger in a notebook
in this video we'll learn how to use a
python debugger in a jupyter notebook or
a collab
for this example we're running code from
the token classification section
downloading the coinol dataset
looking a little bit at the data
before loading a tokenizer to preprocess
the world dataset
check out the section of the course
linked below for more information
once this is done
we try to load eight features from the
training dataset
and then batch them together using
tokenizer.pad
and we get the following error
we use pytorch here with written tensors
equal pt but you'll get the same error
with tensorflow
as we have seen in the how to debug an
error video the error message is at the
end of the traceback here it indexes us
we should use panning which we are
actually trying to do
so this is not useful at all and we'll
need to go a little deeper to debug the
problem
fortunately you can use the python
debugger at any time you get an error in
a jupyter notebook by typing the magic
command debug in a cell
don't forget the percent at the
beginning
when executing that cell you go to the
very bottom of the traceback where you
can type commands that will help you
debug your script
the first two commands you should learn
are u and d for up and down typing u and
enter
will take you up one step in the
traceback to the previous instruction
type d and then enter will take you one
step down in the traceback
going up twice we get to the point zero
was reached
the third command to learn for the
debugger is p for print
it allows you to print any value you
want
for instance
typing p return tensors and enter we see
the value pt that we pass to the pad
function
we can also have a look at the batch
output this patch encoding object gets
the battery output dictionary is a bit
hard to dig into
so let's dive into smaller pieces of it
inside the debugger you can not only
print any variable but also evaluate any
expression
for instance we can have a look at the
input ids keys this batch output object
or the labels keys of this batch output
object
those labels are definitely weird there
are various sizes which we can actually
confirm if we want by printing the size
with a list compression
this is because the pan method of the
tokenizer only takes care of the
tokenizer outputs input ids attention
mask and token diabetes
so we have to patch the labels ourselves
before trying to create a tensor with
them
once you're ready to exit the python
debugger you can press q and enter for
quit
one way to fix zero is to manually pad
the labels to the longest
another way is to use the data collector
specifically designed for token
classification
you can also use the python debugger
directly in the terminal check out the
video link below to learn how